met en scène inspiré vous allez la
retrouver tout au long de cette saison à
Saint-Quentin en Eveline puisqu'elle est
en ce moment avec le roi du bois à la
ferme de baléba à Guy encour où elle
reviendra en mai avec le Médecin volant
vous la retrouverez également en février
au Théâtre de SaintQuentin en Eveline
avec une version très personnelle du SID
voici Sandrine Anglade dans le
kiosque je suis accueillie en fait en
résidence en résidence en partenariat en
campagne onage avec la ferme de de belle
etbas et aussi avec 50 ans en iveline la
scène nationale bon c'est un partenariat
qui dure depuis depuis longtemps avec
avec Jacques Pornon aussi et la scène
nationale là la chance qu'on a c'est de
faire vraiment un point de liaison entre
la scène nationale et la ferme de de
Bell etbas à travers trois spectacles
sur toute la saison
2012-23 là sur ce chemin en plein soleil
où fugacement avait sourit un prince qui
peut-être n'était que marquis je me mise
à pleurer un grand bruit un grand
sanglot j'aurais voulu
brûler le roi du bois donc c'est c'est
l'histoire d'un d'un homme qui se
raconte qui raconte qui raconte son
enfance et ce qu'il est devenu cette
enfance c'était l'enfance d'un jeune
Porché
un jeune homme qui dans l'Italie de la
Renaissance gardait les ports
s'approchant des jardins de Tivoli et
rencontre la peinture les peintres et en
fait c'est cette cet enfant visiblement
brillant enfin et appé en fait par la
main de Claude Le Lurin célèbre peintre
de la Renaissance et il va devenir le
broyeur de couleur l'apprenti il était
Porché il est resté porsché parce que
quand on le retrouve dans l'âge adulte
ben il est à nouveau dans les bois dans
la boue il ne s'en sort pas il ne il ne
il n'arrive pas à devenir autre que ce
qu'il était dans le roi du bois c'est
que finalement l'humanité elle conjugue
tout le temps ces deux aspects au même
instant d'un homme qui a deux corps un
corps bestial et un corps et et un corps
transcendant enfin un corps de de de la
possibilité de s'émerveiller à la grâce
du monde sur le plateau donc c'est
Jacques Bonafé un enfant chanteur un
quoi tu en raccordes qu'écouter ton
amour obéir à sa voix c'était me rendre
indigne et ton choix je te le dis encore
et veux tant que je tant que j'expire
sans cesse le penser et sans cesse le
dire je t'ai fait une offense et j'ai dû
m'y porter pour effacer ma honte et pour
te mériter le S le S mon envie c'est de
c'était encore une fois de travailler
sur la langue d'abord c'était travailler
sur les alexandrins et C envie de faire
une
expérience puisque je n'arrive Arve pas
à concevoir mes spectacles sans musique
c'est comment j'arrive aujourd'hui à
mêler la la musique avec l'alexandrin
j'ai commencé à m'interroger sur le
travail rythmique en fait de
l'alexandrin et on a fait quelques
expériences avec un batteur formidable
qui est Nicolas larminia qui vient
plutôt du jazz et du rock et qui lui
s'est laissé complètement emportter par
par l'alexandrin et du coup on a fait
une version du du du C c'estàd on joue
tout le SID mais B on a contracté par
endroit et puis un travail donc avec une
équipe d'acteurs réduite parce que étant
femme j'étais très intéressé de porter
vraiment très haut les présences de
l'Infante et de chimen comme des
présences à la fois
voilà contradictoire dans leur rapport
aux politique à
l'histoire à la dramaturgie
théâtrale je Sange une chose si vous
piez habiller votre Vallé en médecin il
n rien deus facile à duper que le
bonheur mais c'est un lourdau qui gâre
tout le Médecin volant c'est une très
courte pièce de Molière c'est une pièce
voilà où les médecins volent parce que
en même temps le médecin c'est ce
ganarel qui est qu'un valet qui se fait
passer pour un médecin et du coup il
devient double il est à la fois l'autre
est le même donc c'est c'est très
complexe pour lui parce qu'il faut qu'il
saute par la fenêtre et revienne par la
porte cette pièce moi je l'ai
choisie parce que j'avais très envie de
faire un spectacle vraiment tout public
et pour les très jeunes et ce qui est
formidable chez Molière c'est qu' à la
fois finalement on est touché aussi par
la langue par la beauté poétique de la
langue mais par des tours c'estàd les
plus petits vont s'attacher ils vont
entendre cette langue mais en même temps
ils vont s'attacher à une situation qui
est la situation de de voilà des
bastonnat je saute par la fenêtre je
rentre par la porte et en plus on s'est
amusé à travailler théâtre masqué il y a
un travail sur la musique sur la musique
baroque et là on va faire une petite
expérience à donc on va changer beaucoup
de choses pour la ferme de belle etbas
parce qu'on va en fait avoir un
orchestre de jeunes du du conservatoire
ou de professeur du
conservatoire
et maintenant on retrouve un nouveau
sujet de la rédaction présenté par
Johanna
soudri Sophie vit à M repas elle compose
texte et mélodies depuis plusieurs
années et s'entoure d'autres musiciens
pour former le groupe liliisophare
Alexandre de Mor repa s'occupe des
arrangements Fran originaire de Trapp
joue de la guitare quant à jib également
des ivelin il est percussionniste et
s'intéresse au Baudran un instrument
irlandais c'est on peut dire pop folk le
côté folk pour le les guitares
acoustiques la référence à un instrument
ancien la vielarou et puis sinon ça
reste ça reste pop c'est de la chanson
c'est c'est assez frais la chanson
goldox qui signifie Boucle d'Or en
français s'inspire directement du compte
je repensais à ce compte de Boucle d'Or
Boucle d'Or et les trois ours la petite
fille qui trouve pas bien sa place entre
entre le père la mère et l'enfant et
puis puis en fait en baladant il y avait
un rythme qui venait et et c'est aussi
pour ça que cette chanson est uniquement
rythmique et voix je je voyais pas du
tout de musique dessus je vois les
ombres qui
dansent dans ton regard
immense qui me
h me tourment les ombres c'était c'est
une chanson un peu bizarre en fait qui
est venu suite à une sorte de rêve ou
plutôt de cauchemar j'avais j'avais ce
light motif les ombres les ombres qui me
trotter dans la tête et puis un jour
j'étais un peu énervée je jouais avec un
peu de drage sans sans trop faire
attention à la technique il y avait des
harmoniques qui venaient et petit à
petit il y a ce ce Rif un peu un peu un
peu tlurique un peu aussi très cyclique
qui venait et puis les paroles sont
venues dessus l'iliisophar se produira
vendredi 26 octobre à Saint-Rémy les
chevreuses au théâtre cafart l'album du
groupe n'est pas encore commercialisé
mais Sophie le propose au public lors de
ses concert et sur
Internet et encore quelques dates à
retenir avant d'aller chercher votre
costume d'Halloween le 26 octobre
l'Orchestre National d'île-de-fance
propose une série de portraits musicaux
de femmes exceptionnelles au théâtre de
sa quanttin en Yveline les 30 et 31
octobre au prisme la compagnie
d'idascali s'adressera au petit des 6
ans avec une histoire dansée et
revisitée des trois petits cochons
intitulés dans le ventre du loup tandis
que le 7 novembre c'est la malle au
sortilège qui s'adressera à eux avec de
la musique du monde à entendre au
scarabé à La Verrière le 22 novembre
améican folk blues revue sot en concert
avec leur blues roots à la salle
jacbrell à Montini le Bretonneux et tous
les mardis sachez que vous pouvez gagner
des places de spectacle sur le site du
kiosk
www.kiosk.ski.fr des dates que vous
pouvez retrouver ainsi que l'ensemble de
la programmation des salles
cinquantinoises dans le kiosque sur
Internet aux adresses qui s'affichent
alors bon spectacle à tous et à
bientôt
le C c'est de la balle